from a player's standpoint really only
the second player that we know about
that's had the coronavirus von miller
super bowl 50 mvp
has tested positive is dealing with some
symptoms nothing severe a cough that his
girlfriend thought didn't sound normal
he also has asthma so he falls into that
category of people who have pre-existing
conditions that could possibly make
things worse so far so good he said he
got tested a couple of days ago he
started to feel normal yesterday
and then that's when he found out that
he did indeed come back positive he
joins brian allen the rams center who
tested positive for the coronavirus sean
payton the saints head coach from a few
weeks ago a couple of former players
have died from it but you know this is
the biggest name by far as it relates to
a player and again it's only the second
one we know about but it's von miller
peter and one of the reasons he came
forward with it is he wants people to
realize that it needs to be taken
seriously
yeah i think it's very very good that he
comes out and just talks about it
plainly
because clearly
look in the united states right now mike
so many people who aren't even being
tested are presumed to have the
coronavirus
and i think von miller coming out from
what i read last night i think mike
kliss in denver talked to him
and
his whole point is
let's be
all together transparent i'm going to
tell you exactly how i'm feeling i'm
going to tell you exactly what the
symptoms are so that if you have this
and you are maybe spiraling down a
little bit you've got to call your
healthcare provider and really advocate
to be tested we know that there aren't
enough tests right now in the united
states but the only way you get more is
for people like von miller to come
forward calmly coolly sensibly
and really advocate for better treatment
uh of this deadly disease
it's amazing to me that i've noticed
some people are very circumspect about
acknowledging they have and i understand
medical privacy is an important thing
but at a time like this there's no
stigma to having the coronavirus it's
it's a virus that makes its way through
the population like the flu and that
doesn't mean it is like the flu and i
think the numbers we've seen have shown
otherwise but there's nothing to be
embarrassed about it's more important i
think to make it known especially if
you're someone that people know about
somebody who has a position of
prominence and i applaud von miller and
i hope no one out there who's had it
who's in a position to grab a microphone
and say hey people don't screw around
with this take it seriously continue to
comply with stay-at-home orders continue
to wash your hands continue to not touch
your face continue to do everything
you've been doing because this is real
and it's not good if you have it so
hopefully people
whether it's in football other sports
celebrities whoever if you get it make
it known that you have it there's
nothing to be embarrassed about because
anyone can get it and a lot more people
will get it if the most prominent people
in our society have it and keep their
mouths shut about it
yeah and i think i really liked
the fact that tony baselli both to me
and to several other people
came out recently and basically said hey
listen i had it
excuse me i had it here's what it was
and here's the warning signs of it and
here's what you really
should be careful to avoid and so those
are the kind of things because look mike
you know that probably you and i i know
i do
i spend a couple of hours every day
even now in the middle of draft mayhem i
spent a couple of hours every day
looking and seeing what the latest is
whether i'm watching
governor cuomo talk here in new york
where i live or or watching some of the
uh
president trump's stuff in the evening
or just watching the news i've really
gotten into watching the pbs news hour
with my wife after dinner and so i am
really trying to get as much news i can
but the fact is
that probably the vast majority of
people in our country
don't do that or i should say the
majority because you know a lot of
people when the news is a bummer they
say hey i'm going to watch cheers the
reruns and cheers or whatever and
i don't blame them at all for doing that
but i do think it's good when somebody
who's a very prominent member of our
society
stands up and says i've got it here's
what i'm feeling if you feel anything
like it don't ignore it
and let me tell you it is difficult to
continue to stay up with the news of
this it wears you out mentally and
emotionally and i have reduced the
amount of time that i will subject
myself to this every day i'll watch
brian williams on msnbc at 11 p.m
eastern that's not a plug it's a fact
and i'll watch some of the nightly news
with lester hold on nbc at 6 30 pm
eastern again that sounds like a plug
it's not it's a fact beyond that i can't
hover all day long on cable news
channels anymore peter after three or
four weeks of it i just reached my limit
it's it's this it's this weight that you
carry around every day but you still
want to know what's going on and i think
now that we're getting into this debate
as to when the world is going to get
back to normal we need this reminder
that people are still going to get it
because we need that reminder that we
still have to be careful because
people far above our pay grade will be
making the decision about when the world
begins to go back to normal and that's
when the risk is going to be
heightened dramatically for a lot of
people once the doors on society open up
again even if and again i don't i'm not
expressing any opinion about when they
should all i know is i can already sense
that there will be a sharp disagreement
as to when the world is ready to get
back to normal
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports